[Música]
tengo un temita con la verdad y con las
conversaciones
me formé como científica pero terminé
tomando caminos extraños
la ciencia es una manera de hacerle
preguntas al mundo y de escuchar sus
respuestas
nunca sabremos todo pero eso no quiere
decir que no sepamos nada hay muchos que
ya sabemos
sin embargo la evidencia a veces es
dejada de lado a la hora de tomar
decisiones o de formarnos una imagen del
mundo
por ejemplo ya sabemos que el cambio
climático es una realidad pero hay
quienes lo niegan
ya sabemos que las vacunas funcionan y
son seguras
pero también hay quienes dudan
esa fue mi primera decepción
las evidencias son necesarias pero no
suficientes
con esto se me abrió un nuevo camino
pensé que el problema era la educación
así que dejé el laboratorio y me dediqué
a enseñar amo la docencia el aula es uno
de mis lugares preferidos pero ahí
encontré el mismo problema que antes
estaba enseñando sobre vacunas y una
estudiante dijo que ella no se vacunaba
porque las vacunas le parecían
peligrosas
y mi intuición fue
dice esto porque no sabe del tema si le
explico va a cambiar su postura
le expliqué pero no funcionó
la evidencia no alcanza
la educación no alcanza
segunda decepción
esto que me pasó con mi estudiante fue
mi primera experiencia personal con la
post verdad
eso qué pasa cuando aunque la
información esté se deja de lado y se
siguen las emociones o las creencias
con esto se abrió un nuevo camino
será un problema de comunicación
como la ciencia es una herramienta la
use para estudiarla por verdad
empecé a conversar con personas que
desconfían de las vacunas y encontrarme
con médicos y periodistas para tratar de
mejorar la comunicación sobre el tema
y ahí entendí que nunca había aprendido
a conversar con los que piensan distinto
por ejemplo
como dialogamos cuando el problema no es
la evidencia sino un desacuerdo
ideológico
hay experimentos que muestran que cuando
la gente conversa solamente con los que
piensan igual sus opiniones se vuelven
más extremas y homogéneas
pero para tener una democracia saludable
no necesitamos que los que piensan
distinto logren conversaciones amplias
honestas y profundas
esto no es lo que está pasando
cada discusión cada desacuerdo cada
conversación parece una batalla entre el
bien y el mal
nuestras opiniones en vez de ser
provisorias puentes para comunicarnos
con otros son inamovibles una zanja que
acabamos y que separa a los que están de
nuestro lado de los otros
el diálogo desaparece el acuerdo es
imposible y el mundo se fragmenta en una
combinación explosiva de agresión y
desconfianza
y podemos hacer algo
no todas las opiniones nacen iguales
algunas son débiles o temporarias
otras son intensas o duraderas
y otras se vuelven parte de nuestra
identidad
cuando pasa eso cualquier duda sobre lo
que pensamos se vuelve una duda acerca
de quiénes somos y eso nos resulta
insoportable
además la necesidad de proteger nuestra
integridad nos hace agruparnos por los
que están en la misma situación
esto es el tribalismo
por eso a veces ni la evidencia ni la
educación funcionan
no pensamos algo somos ese algo
les hago una pregunta
les pasó alguna vez de ir a una reunión
social en donde hay personas que no
conocen y pensar algo como
no sé qué piensa esta gente mejor de tal
tema no hablo les pasó a ver levanten la
mano los que vivieron algo así
mírense
el daño del tribalismo no es solo que
genera un clima de conflicto permanente
sino también que genera silencios
algunos nos retiramos del debate pero no
porque no tengamos opiniones o no nos
importe lo que pasa
no somos tibios
por el clima de agresión porque las
cosas no avanzan
por miedo por hartazgo por la
penalización social del descenso por uno
o varios de estos motivos abandonamos la
conversación en silencio
es un silencio ruidoso
y así la imposibilidad de dialogar hace
que el número de voces disminuya a veces
hasta que queda una sola
se confunde silencio con asentimiento y
se crea una ilusión de consenso
como se oye una sola opinión parece que
hay una sola opinión y entonces
cualquier otra opinión ya no es
solamente distinta es disonante es ajena
y debe ser eliminada
en general asociamos la idea de censura
con la de un poder que prohíbe desde
arriba pero hay otra forma más sutil la
censura desde abajo
la que a través de herramientas de
disciplinamiento social como por ejemplo
subiendo el tono de la pelea genera que
nos retiremos
esto es una amenaza a la libre expresión
y me hace pensar que también es un
problema para la democracia tanto en
nuestro pequeño entorno como a gran
escala
parecería entonces que hay sólo dos
opciones
o mostramos nuestras ideas despreciando
a los que no piensan como nosotros o nos
callamos y al hacer eso cedemos el
control a los que deciden hablar pero
esto es un falso dilema hay otra opción
pero necesitamos volverla evidente
porque estaba oculta en este mar de
tribalismo
podemos tener posturas definidas incluso
muy intensas sin subirnos a la dinámica
del discurso intolerante
es una de las cosas que aprendí al
hablar con las personas que dudan de las
vacunas
para romper con el tribalismo
para buscar la mayor cantidad de voces
para salir de esta dinámica de amigos y
enemigos
propongo distinguir entre que creemos y
como lo creemos
y si a este como lo volvemos no tribal
podemos plantear nuestras opiniones sin
que lo que pensamos se convierta en lo
que somos
reaparecen los matices y las
conversaciones se vuelven imposibles
y a partir de ahí se pueden construir
consensos que son productos de lograr
acuerdos a pesar de nuestras diferencias
pero cuando hablo de estas ideas me
suelen hacer algunas críticas por
ejemplo que parece que con tal de evitar
los conflictos planteo dejar que los
consensos de kant en donde sea no no es
eso lo que quiero decir
si no nos expresamos porque nos sentimos
alienados o expulsados
no estamos participando de la toma de
decisiones
pero todos vivimos con las consecuencias
de esas decisiones entonces como no nos
da todo lo mismo necesitamos hablar
pero si no queremos hablar en este clima
hostil porque nos agota y vemos que no
lleva a nada tratemos de superar el modo
tribal más allá de lo que pensemos
quizás tengamos más en común con quienes
piensan distinto pero quieren conversar
y con los que comparten con nosotros
alguna opinión pero son intolerantes
también me suelen decir que no hay mucho
que podamos hacer a nivel individual
para salir del modo tribal pero me
parece que si hay cosas para hacer bien
concretas y tengo tres sugerencias que
podrían ayudar
primero buscar el pluralismo promoverlo
activamente
así el descenso se vuelve visible y esto
es importante porque solo si incluimos
el descenso podemos lograr un verdadero
consenso
para que esto pueda pasar necesitamos
poder hablar sin sentir que se nos
penaliza socialmente
pero también hace falta que seamos
capaces de escuchar voces que no nos
gustan
el momento de defender la libertad de
expresión es ahora
cuidarla es más fácil que recuperarla
aprender a conversar mejor a encontrar
mejores maneras de estar en desacuerdo
conversar no es esperar nuestro turno
para hablar tratando de imponer nuestras
ideas por la fuerza o la insistencia
es escuchar para entender al otro
sin escucha no hay conversación
tercero
separar las ideas de las personas
bajo el tribalismo atacar una idea hace
que la persona se sienta amenazada
porque siente que se la ataca como
persona
pero con esa actitud
cómo vamos a lograr mejorar las ideas
necesitamos discutir las para que
sobrevivan las mejores las personas
merecen respeto
las ideas tienen que ganárselo
los humanos somos inventores
en algún punto en algún lugar inventamos
la idea de sentarnos junto al fuego a
conversar
y en un punto las conversaciones y el
fuego se parecen
los dos están siempre entre dos peligros
el de extinguirse y el de crecer de modo
descontrolado
nos llevó tiempo pero aprendimos a usar
el fuego aprendimos a mantenerlo vivo
para que no se apague
y a manejarlo para que no nos destruya
quizás llegó la hora de aprender a hacer
lo mismo con las conversaciones
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y